un moteur d'un airbus a320 sur le poste
de travail de josé et thibault ces deux
techniciens aéronautique du site safran
aircraft engines de magny les hameaux
font un contrôle une inspection à
l'intérieur de la turbine du moteur
grâce à un endoscope et à voir
une mauvaise température au niveau
beyblade de la turbine mais apparemment
elle est propre le contrôle se poursuit
aussi sur les différentes parties du
moteur donc ici à l'avant nous avons la
partie soufflante la partie suivante
c'est le ventilateur en fait c'est lui
qui va aspirer l'air pour envoyer à
l'intérieur du compresseur en fait qui
est composé de la chambre de combustion
et du compresseur
donc c'est là que l'air va être comprimé
dans cette partie là
donc ce sont des plusieurs étages des
lettres qui vont se réduire et comprimer
l'air et qui vont l'amener dans la
chambre de combustion ici nous avons ici
donc la dernière partie est en fait
c'est cette partie là qui va entraîner
donc les blade à l'avant et qui va faire
que le moteur va faire décoller l'avion
c'est ce qui va donner la puissance
démontage et remontage des moteurs
d'avion réparation nettoyage ou contrôle
de certaines pièces
le quotidien des 700 salariés de cette
usine implantée à saint quentin en
yvelines depuis 1990 pour démonter un
moteur à partir du moment où ils
arrivent chez nous jusqu'à la pièce
unitaire il faut compter une semaine une
grosse semaine
ensuite vous avez les opérations de
lavage donc ça c'est trois jours le
contrôle une quinzaine de jours puis
leur montage qui fait qu'un moteur est
chez nous un peu plus de deux mois
airbus a380 boeing 737 max airbus a320
neo ou encore boeing 777
ce site soit près de 15 moteur par mois
directement en provenance des compagnies
aériennes on est plutôt en croissance
d'activité
le trafic aérien est en croissance
importante et bien
nous embauchons en moyenne une
cinquantaine de personnes chaque année
principalement des moteurs aéronautiques
des contrôleurs aéronautique des
techniciens l'adaptation aux nouveaux
systèmes installés sur les moteurs
nouvelle génération le défi de demain
pour le site safran aircraft engines de
magny les hameaux